good afternoon my name is David Bob I
serve as director of the Allen P Kirby
jr. center for constitutional studies
and citizenship of Hillsdale College
welcome to today's lecture our topic is
Washington DC monuments and memorials
old and new we're pleased today to be
joined by Michael J Lewis who is a
professor of art at Williams College and
today we owe him special thanks for this
lecture as throughout this week he's
been battling laryngitis and had
canceled his classes but the show must
go on and so today he's here to offer
this lecture and looks forward to all of
your questions this lecture series is
sponsored by Chris and Sarah ciccolo
we're grateful for their support and
making it possible it's a monthly
lecture series and at the end of today's
event all I'll note are upcoming talk
for the month of April today I'm going
to start just by noting a couple of
things for those of you who are joining
us on the online audience and that is
that you may also participate in the Q&A
session and may submit questions to us
via email at First Fridays at Hillsdale
edu will also invite you to click on the
PowerPoint presentation which will
accompany today's lecture it is right
there by your viewer and you can see
that online for those of you who are
with us today you can find that then in
the archived version as well to
introduce our speaker this morning I
would like to ask Hillsdale College
Junior Daniel Anderson to come forward
dan this semester is interning at
Freedom Works and he's a major in
political economy Daniel
good afternoon Michael J Lewis is the
fussin Pearson Stoddard professor of art
at Williams College in architectural
critic he is the author of the Gothic
Revival american art and architecture
and the prize-winning argost reisen's
Berger the politics of the German Gothic
Revival a recipient of the Guggenheim
Fellowship he has taught at Bryn Mawr
College McGill University and the
University of Natal South Africa he
received his BA from Harvard College and
his PhD from the University of
Pennsylvania today he will be speaking
on the topic Washington DC monuments and
memorials old and new please join me in
welcoming dr. Michael Lewis
thank you I really don't have much of a
voice forgive me this has been a
remarkable year for the making of
monuments in this city and elsewhere the
memorial at Ground Zero opened last
September in New York Michael
a-rod's mournful subterranean shrine
that occupies the exact footprint of the
missing towers
one month later came the dedication of
the Martin Luther King memorial here in
Washington shown at the bottom and soon
to come to Washington or perhaps not is
the memorial to President Eisenhower
which is to be a collaboration between
architect Frank Gehry and the sculptor
Charles Rea I show their model here each
of these monuments has been the subject
of furious controversy especially in
Washington the Martin Luther King
memorial was criticized for engaging a
sculptor from communist China who
promptly saw to it that Chinese granite
was used for the structure in place of
American granite which is abundant all
of which accounts for the made in China
inscription here in this cartoon even
worse the memorial managed to misquote
the great man in two ways not only did
he never say I was a drum major for
peace just a justice peace and
righteousness but his actual words were
a hypothetical statement put in someone
else's mouth this is not the worst of
failings inscriptions can be recarved as
we have learned but what has anchored
critics and not merely conservative
critics but leaders in the civil rights
movement is the demeanor and the
expression of the sculpture because King
was above all an orator and in the
images we have of him he is in Vera
variably open in stance speaking
gesturing gesticulating otherwise
engaging with the public the energy of
his life for
was directed outward and yet in the King
memorial he is depicted with his arms
folded utterly detached as if
hermetically sealed and self-contained
instead of the inspiring warmth of the
man there was only the infinite
aloofness of an idol now as it happens
the proposed Eisenhower manya Monument
has been criticized on the opposite
grounds instead of making it subject to
30-foot effigy it turns him instead into
a barefoot diminutive country boy the
proposal calls for an outdoor public
place that is not quite a formal Civic
Plaza not quite an urban park columns in
the background will support a wire mesh
that will depict images of the Kansas
prairie the site of Eisenhower's
childhood and at the center will be the
sculpture of the man himself not
monumental but life-size presumably
along the lines of the similar statue at
his birthplace in Abilene here too there
has been great disbelief and dismay
after all there were millions of
barefoot country boys but only one
commander-in-chief of the Allies in
World War two who led the great fight of
freedom against tyranny now the odd
configuration of the Eisenhower Memorial
which officer offers no culminating
focal point but instead presents
multiple images and attractions is not
surprising when one looks at the work of
its author Frank Gehry whose Guggenheim
Museum in Bilbao is one of the most
sensational buildings of the last
generation but Gary's fluttering and
writhing forms at which he excels are
the stuff of spectacle and are hardly
the training ground to prepare one to
make a statement of tragic dignity which
is the theme of every monument and so
like the king
and has come in for ridicule as depicted
here on the back of an $11 bill
proclaiming in Gary we trust now as
different as these memorials are the
public's disappointment in each case has
been this has had the same cause these
aren't the men we knew this is not
Eisenhower the victorious general
president of integrity and vision this
is not Martin Luther King the
impassioned orator I share the dismay
but let's face it it is not easy to make
a succinct statement in sculptural form
of the essence of a man's life but this
is something that American art has
always struggled with in our chronic
divided loyalty between realism and
idealism as a population we tend to be
literal minded and idealistic and
invariably we struggle to mix the two as
the sculptor Horatio green Oh did when
he placed a realistic bust of George
Washington on the body of the Olympian
Zeus in 1842 the great consternation of
the public there's something wrong here
but contemporaries were not sure exactly
what it was whatever it was it was not
what one perturbed viewer thought which
is that the father of our country would
never be so imprudent as to expose his
body to the air after a bath but I
propose that this is the least of the
problems with the Eisenhower and King
memorials the problem that they fail to
hit exactly the right note I want to
suggest today that the problem goes
deeper and that they fail they fail
fundamentally and unnecessarily as
monuments not because they misunderstand
the nature of their subject but because
they misunderstand the nature of a
monument they do not even know what a
monument is or should be
if this is the case then we have a
bigger problem than a pair of
ill-advised and clumsy works of
contemporary public art how do you
define a monument for purposes of our
talk today let us say that a monument is
the expression of a single powerful idea
in a single emphatic form colossal in
scale permanent in materials and
projected into public space something
very small smaller than our own body for
example cannot be a monument although it
might be a memorial such as a bronze
plaque on the wall too much is made of
the distinction between monuments and
memorials I suspect but I think if asked
Frank Gehry would say something quite
different he would argue that a monument
is not a thing but a process an
open-ended conversation in which in
which various constituencies bring
different interpretations to different
forms I have heard versions of this
definite definition throughout my career
but for reasons I want to make clear
today this is simply not good enough
let me explain we have all seen these
those spontaneous roadside memorials
those improvised votive offerings that
mark the site of a traffic fatality they
are a relatively new phenomenon only a
generation or so old one did not see
them before the 1980s as physical
objects their mere ephemera but as a
mass cultural phenomenon they are quite
important and they testify to a deep and
unfulfilled human need for memorials a
need that for whatever the reason is not
being met today once you begin to look
for these you find them everywhere all
over all over the roads of Virginia I
think particularly in Virginia here is a
completely new form of
folk art and you'll note that it is
immediately extremely conventionalized
in its expression notice for one thing
how extremely narrow is the repertoire
of forms and materials crosses flowers
hand-painted signs and heartbreakingly
in the case of a child stuffed animals
but there is very little else little
striving for originality they seek to
find generally understood symbols which
they use to achieve resolution and
closure they certainly do not speak of
an open-ended process and in a way these
roadside anonymous sculptors understand
what many contemporary artists do not
and that is that monumentality because
it is a public form of art must be
legible and this requires convention as
with human speech we invent new
sentences but we use old words and it is
for this reason that most traditional
monuments are variants of a few ancient
types the triumph arch the colossal
column the obelisk and the temple if you
go to Rome and see the Pantheon you'll
see one in front of the other mm-hmm now
since the 1930s it has been fashionable
to disparage all of this has so much
architectural grave-robbing deferring to
classical antiquity rather than creating
our own forms but we should not think of
these forms so much as ancient as
timeless after all the arch is nothing
more than a space of passage made
monumental an obelisk or a column is
nothing more than an exclamation point
raised above a sacred spot a temple is
simply a tabernacle the sacred tent
raised above an altar these ideas are
unchanging and it is not surprising that
the one truly successful work of
contemporary
public art the Vietnam Memorial took for
its form one of the most ancient of all
the mural shrine the Wailing Wall and
because of their ability to transcend
time by connecting themselves to primal
human qualities activities passage
gathering shelter that the best monument
somehow never seemed dated an object
like the Jefferson Memorial
John Russell Pope's masterpiece does not
make us think of 1940 but at Thomas
Jefferson and it with the most effective
means possible shape alone to
commemorate the finest intellect ever to
be President author of the Declaration
of Independence the Bill of Rights
Pope chose the most perfect of all forms
the sphere a physical manifestation of
the clarity of his mind how different
the Lincoln Memorial that Foursquare
Citadel here the theme is heroic
fortitude a cincture of closely spaced
columns huddled together about the
windowless central shrine expressing not
clarity but endurance and different yet
again the Washington Monument which
fittingly is a vehement founding gesture
a single bold mark against the sky and
for this the model was that greatest of
architectural point markers the obelisk
of the Egyptians that pointer of the
sundial that connected the earth to the
Sun to tell us when time itself began
each of these structures makes a single
great claim and it is this single
nespresso monumental a monument can only
say one thing we honor we celebrate we
endured we won or even we grieve we
grieve this is the message of Maya Lin's
Vietnam Veterans Memorial
which demonstrated that it is not
necessary to be neoclassical to be
monumental the vast sweep of space the
simplicity of materials just earth and
stone and the massive authority of a
single lucid shape all these are
monumental in the best sense perhaps the
most poetic gesture of all is the way
she solved the problem of listing the
names of all the some 58,000 dead it was
determined that they should appear in
order of the date of death rather than
alphabetically which gave the whole
structure the character of a long sad
calendar of death but she did not simply
start at one end in 1959 and continue on
through to 1975 the last names fading
away in the earth instead she began and
ended the timeline in the center at the
vertex so that the name of the last to
die would touch the name of the first to
die he or she gave the monument a point
of repose a moment of resolution the
point where things begin and end which
transforms a linear timeline into
something cyclical and regenerative and
makes its central moment a kind of alter
not very long ago it was fashionable to
sneer at these things Frank Lloyd Wright
found the Jefferson Memorial
preposterous the equivalent of flying a
modern airplane while wearing a toga as
it happens though he wrote his attack
against the memorial some seventy years
ago and there are good many things from
1940 which now look much more dated than
the Jefferson Memorial but true
monumentality as myelin revealed has
little to do with style and everything
to do with simplicity the great sculptor
Rodin said when asked to define
sculpture supposedly this may be
apocryphal
he said that sculpture is what happens
when you roll a statue down the flight
of steps well what happens is everything
incidental breaks off the gesticulating
hands the props the swords the head
perhaps leaving only a powerful torso
free of incident or digression there is
a splendid word for this laconic style
of expression lapidary which comes from
the latin word lapis stone lapidary was
the roman turned for the vision for the
verbal compression necessary when when
is carving an inscription in stone I
suppose the modern version would be
telegram style when you used to have to
pay for every word but somehow now
telegrams seem even more ancient than
inscriptions mmm and so like the
inscriptions they bear the best
monuments are lapidary they have that
splendid economy of expression that
comes from saying one thing and saying
it monumentally but the minute a
monument tries to say more than many
more than one thing and to say many
things it is no longer a monument but a
Russian novel as we see as we see in
that most garrulous of Washington
memorials the Franklin Delano Roosevelt
memorial which is monumental alas only
in its verbosity the memorial was
designed by Lawrence Halprin
was sculptured by George Segal and
provides a sequence of four outdoor
rooms corresponding to Roosevelt's four
terms each presents a visual tableau
lavishly outfitted with bronze statues
relief sculpture and inscriptions for
example the first term is dramatized
with a vignette of the Depression era
breadline showing the us the despair and
misery at the moment Roosevelt took
office it is an unsettling image
probably because it is an attempt to
render in sculpture the kind of imagery
we know from photographs of the era such
as Dorothea Langa's breadline
in the next room we have a vignette of
an American listening intently to one of
Roosevelt's fireside chats another image
of hard times
notice the bare feet but also the
gesture of leaning into the radio a
poignant a poignant image of listening
with hope through all of this runs an
insistent literalism nothing is rendered
abstractly
or symbolically it's a kind of cross
pollination of a diorama in a museum
with Madame Tussauds Wax Museum
we even have FDR's dog fala panting Lee
immortalized in bronze but despite all
these discursive tableaus this visual
wordiness the memorial is sometimes
quite at a loss for words during the
design process anti-smoking groups
succeeded in eliminating Roosevelt's bic
wouldest cigarette holder evidently
Halperin and his collaborators did not
recognize that Roosevelt's cigarette
holder was not the sign of a lamentable
addiction it was the president's most
effective visual prop he clenched it in
his teeth with his jaw thrust forward so
that it pointed upwards jauntily to
create an image of buoyant unshakable
optimism but even as the cigarette was
excised pressure from activist groups
for the disabled ensured that Roosevelt
would be depicted as Weil
wheelchair-bound
and handicapped with polio a fact he
carefully suppressed in his public
appearances and so the element he
flaunted was eliminated the element he
concealed was stressed and so Roosevelt
that rakish and jaunty cavalier
was transformed into a differently-abled
and rather prim nonsmoker I can't help
think that Roosevelt was a much more
gifted creator of inspiring visual
imagery than the makers of his own
Monument by the way you will notice
behind Roosevelt is a quotation that is
a generic attack on totalitarianism
which is utterly unremarkable what is
remarkable is what it should say
December 7th 1941 a date that will live
in infamy so for a memorial that has
otherwise so garrulous here again it is
at a loss for words by the way this is
by no means the most outrageous
reinvention of Roosevelt at this very
moment on Roosevelt Island in New York
the Roosevelt Island memorial to by
Louis Kahn is now being built at the
southern tip of the island will
eventually be a colossal bust of the
president which may well prove
successful to judge from the model it's
too early to tell but nearby is to be a
second inspirational sculpture dedicated
to Roosevelt's handicap the intentions
to be sure are good and the sculpture is
to be based on a photograph that is
actually quite touching of Roosevelt in
his wheelchair with the young girl in
her polio braces padding fala but great
intentions are no guarantee of great art
and it is almost never a good idea to
base a three-dimensional work of art on
a two-dimensional image one hesitates at
this point to criticize the sculpture
since we only have the model but my
sense is that it will be very pious very
earnest very heartwarming but by no
means a great work of art and yet it
tells much about the state of monuments
today in its discursive nough
sentimentality its addiction to
narrative literalism in place of
allegory
Gouri and asking to be judged on its
intentions rather than its visual
coherence how do we get to this point
ironically it began with a reaction
against overwrought memorials of the
Victorian era things such as the Albert
Memorial in in London with its
comprehensive allegory of English
cultural scientific and political life
which seems to want to tell you about
everything even the four continents with
their distinctive inhabitants animal
human and otherwise are all present so
manages manages in good Victorian
fashion to be a monument and an
encyclopedia so here's a kind of visual
access not too far removed from the FDR
memorial but perhaps the most bombastic
of all was the victim Emmanuel monument
in Rome piece of colossal opera scenery
serving merely as backdrop to an
equestrian statue it was this overblown
rhetoric that convinced modern
architects that we needed a new language
of monumentality and so while modernism
went about dismantling the structures of
traditional society culture religion the
political social order even the family
it soon came to about dismantling arches
and columns that had paid tribute to
that same traditional order but this is
not as easy as it sounds because
modernism is concerned with reform in
the future looking forward not backward
and because monuments are always
retrospective it was difficult to find a
modernist language of monumentality
still there were fascinating attempts
probably the best is vladimir tatlin
designed for a monument to the third
international but if modern technology
did not seem to lend itself easily to
the making of monuments it got better in
the 1960s there came a movement of
monumental art we now know as Earth art
it culminated in the late 60s with the
first Earth Day of
1969 one year after the publication of
Paul Ehrlich's Population Bomb that
immensely influential an immensely
destructive book and there's no there's
no question that it could achieve
genuine monumentality look at Robert
Smithson Spiral Jetty in the Great Salt
Lake although in the end we should
perhaps classify it as a verb as a
species of ante monument for it is
deliberately cryptic and obscure in its
meaning as cryptic as a cave painting
and as I propose monumental expression
requires lucidity Maya Lin's Vietnam
Monument came less than a decade after
Spiral Jetty
and it is in the same tradition of
earthworks shaping the earth through
mounds and embankments but we forget how
furious the reception was when it was
first shown so so vehement was the
opposition to it that it could only
built be built with the addition of a
group of realistic figural sculpture the
fighting men by the late Frederick Hart
this depiction of a trio of combat
infantrymen returning grim drenched
weary back from a Patrol we can imagine
them here stepping out of a clearing and
if your taste is for the realistic and
sculpture hearts are the best he
actually did the bronze doors to the
washington cathedral but then something
curious happened hart carefully made a
point of depicting a black a white and a
hispanic soldier but he did not depict a
woman and shortly after the monument was
augmented by yet a third memorial this
time honoring the women who died in
vietnam the sculptor selected was Glenna
Goodacre who paraphrased Michelangelo's
pietà and not badly the wounded soldier
reposes like the dead Christ in the
nurses lap and a place of Michelangelo's
billowing skirts for his Madonna we have
here a pyramid of sandbags a skillful
adaptation
it is so skillful I am chagrin to
confessed that Glenna Goodacre is also
the designer of the Sacagawea dollar
coin that most unloved 'add item of
American currency but there's a problem
here
the fact is 7 women died during the war
who are represented here by three
statues what about the other four notice
the math heart represented 58,000 dead
soldiers with three statues Goodacre has
three who represent seven women dead we
are rapidly approaching the point where
we are no longer dealing with symbolism
but a straight one-to-one representation
and I'm afraid to say that this was the
ultimate lesson of the Vietnam Memorial
while America's most flagrantly
progressive and avant-garde artists
openly mocked Fredric arts fighting men
for the realism when it came time for
them to propose their own monuments
fashionable designers such as Garry or
Halperin preferred easygoing literalism
to the sublime abstraction of Milan for
example the Korean memorial begun in
1988 by the sculptor Frank Gaylord tried
to have the best of both worlds merging
maya lin's wall with hearts fighting men
here the subject is again of platoon on
Patrol
in this case nineteen bronze soldiers
trudging heavily uphill burdened by
heavy ponchos you have the sense of the
harsh Korean winter now it was
originally intended to depict not
nineteen but thirty eight soldiers
representing the 38th parallel along
which the war pivoted in the end it was
cut in half
presumably for reasons of budget with
the unbelievably lame justification that
it would be doubled by the reflecting
mirror of the back wall nineteen times
two equals thirty eight get it
we get it here is an utter
misunderstanding of the means and ends
of allegory normally allegory uses
interlocking symbols to comment on the
things that matter truth honor sacrifice
life here it is inverted something that
really matters human lives are being
used to represent something that is only
an accident of military geography an
imaginary line in the earth now how can
it be that this language of allegory
once generally understood by our culture
as a whole has been banished from
America's most sacred sites banished so
completely that in order to find a
living example of it I have to find a
roadside Virginia shrine for an
unambiguous statement of grief and love
I believe it has something to do with
this in the 1960s there spread the idea
that we no longer needed formal
conventions the conventions of etiquette
what we needed was authenticity and
sincerity we didn't need this we needed
we needed we needed to be genuine those
of us over 50 me and a couple of you
remember how the mantra of that arrow
was to tell it like it is
we were urged to speak from the heart
man to improvise and if the improve
ation faltered as it often does well in
that case stumbling inarticulate 'no
stakin as a badge of sincerity but of
course this Emily Post tells us there
are situations that are that are too
serious to trust to improvisation there
are moments when you need a convention
and you cannot improve upon it by
felicitous extemporize ation the polite
inquiry how are you the statement of
well wishes I wish you the best the
statement of condolence I'm sorry for
your loss
these are not trite platitudes but they
are conventions
and social interaction requires social
convention the problem is that those
people who refuse to use conventional
sayings such as I am sorry for your loss
run the danger of saying something
original
but inappropriate like well at least
he's out of his misery or that's a
bummer or my uncle had a similar tumor
in other words ghastly things in other
words if you trust to your originality
all that you can be sure of is that
whatever inappropriate notion that is
bobbing along at the top of your
unconscious will be blurted out and as
it is with social etiquette so it is
with memorials the Vietnam Memorial
succeeds because it says and in the
simplest terms possible I am sorry for
your loss
if one tries to say anything else if one
tries to add to that statement make it
original one risks vulgarity indecency
or even worse as the attacks of 9/11
made clear on that day a day that will
live in infamy the most agonizing of all
images were those of those trapped
workers in those towers who their backs
to the inferno left to their deaths some
200 in all we can only look at an image
like this with reverence and compassion
and with our prayers and yet look at it
it is a very human image it is our pietà
it reminds us of our own mortality it is
part of the great common human
experience it cries out for an artistic
response but an artist who would sweep
away the traditional conventions for
dealing with the great truths of life
and death and sacrifice if you do that
all you have left is to snuffle about
the cupboard of your own storehouse of
mental images and such as the fate of
the first artist who tried to make
monumental art out of 911 Eric Fischl
who made a colossal bronze that he
called falling woman this is what
happens when you trust to improvisation
rather than saying I am sorry for your
loss it is saying I cannot get this out
of my head
but this is not public art this is
private indulgence so in the end the
Ground Zero memorial was not as bad as I
feared but not as good as it should have
been the key decision was of course to
maintain the footprint of the towers
which unfortunately means that the
dominant expression is the collapse of
the buildings themselves and not the
lives within if it has something of the
laconic restraint of the Vietnam
Memorial this is to be expected because
myelin was on the jury and played a
prominent role and in effect she created
an urban version of her landscape
memorial the same sense of void absence
the same minimalism the same remote
austerity but in one respect though and
a critical respect it fails to achieve
the spatial resolution of Vietnam the
bringing together of all its energy at a
single point at Vietnam the names are in
order of the sequence of death and have
a kind of sad rhythm but obviously this
could not be done at Ground Zero were
effectively all died at the same moment
and so the names there are placed
according to random computer generated
sequence let me make a modest suggestion
in the future in a monument there must
be nothing random or computer-generated
so let me conclude let me return to the
monuments in Washington that have been
so controversial this season
the Eisenhower project we can now see is
scarcely a memorial let alone a monument
its principal object the sculpture of
Eisenhower as a farm boy is dwarfed by
the colossal backdrop that surrounds him
it will be these images abstract
depictions of the Kansas countryside
photographic images of Eisenhower's life
that provide the dominant visual note
equally distressing is the mesh of iron
that is intended to depict the kanzen
topography shown here in a test
installation one wag has called this the
Eisen curtain Eisen is the German word
for iron tear down this wall
lost lost and adrift somewhere in this
theme park of billboards and fragmented
colonnades is diminutive Eisenhower
himself diminutive and diminished and
probably a bit bewildered what does this
have to say about the guiding spirit of
d-day d-day was an act of greatness and
this memorial expresses if anything a
distinct uneasiness with greatness
what about the Martin Luther King
memorial here it seems to be too much
greatness and greatness of the wrong
sort the most familiar charge is that it
recalls the despotic sculpture of
Leninist Maoist regimes with their
avuncular butts turn dear leaders and to
be fair the sculptor Lee hee
Shin has spent his entire life in such a
culture and it is to be expected that
his design would be a kind of surrogate
mal image and to be sure there is
something imperious and implacable about
the face of King a kind of lithic
ruthlessness it certainly seems far
fiercer than that of our other national
martyr to you
rights Abraham Lincoln I want to propose
that the difference here is not so much
between American and Chinese values
although they are at play but between
granite and marble Kane has carved out
of granite a dense stone with a
crystalline structure that is carved
with the greatest of effort it forces a
language of sharp lines flat plains and
a generalized roundness the marble out
of which Lincoln is carved is a more
supple material permitting a soft
descriptive modeling of cheek foreheads
an atomic specificity when one looks at
King with his little eyes those double
eye lines delineating eyes and lips one
realized that this is really the most
primal sculptural language of all that
of ancient Egypt Egypt as seen here in
pharaoh ramses ii an icon shaped to
match the unyielding crystalline
compactness of granite and so it would
be convenient if we could simply dismiss
the king memorial as a sublimated item
of totalitarian leader worship our
quarrel is really with the granite if
one builds statuary for the outdoors
this is the material one must use but
there is a far greater problem with the
King memorial and this has to do with
its overall conception it was inspired
by a line from King's I have a dream
speech which promises that together we
will build out of a mountain of despair
a stone of hope and in case anyone
nodding off has missed the point here's
the mountain of despair and there is the
stone of Hope advancing forward like a
pond on a chessboard in other words just
as the King memorial relegated its human
figures into symbols of the 38th
parallel here king himself is downgraded
to an illustration of his own wordplay a
figure of speech is beautiful because it
calls to mind
mental picture but actually to build a
scale model of a metaphor is to do it
violence and to render laughable in
reality what is beautiful in the
imagination somehow Kings greatness is
diminished by confining it within the
precincts of his own wordplay a monument
should be limitless let me give an
example in 1880 the great american
architect richardson was commissioned to
design a monument to the ames family the
creators of the Continental the
Transcontinental Railroad the site was
the Hyatt highest elevation of that
railroad near Billings Montana
Richardson crafted an idiosyncratic
pyramid which towards the ground
Huddle's low like a squatting wrestler
trying to find his center of gravity
gathering his contained force before he
leaps upward at a sharper angle here is
a depiction of the mental energy needed
to create the railroad abstractly
rendered first the gathering of mental
force and then the release of that force
imagine if this were designed today by
Frank Gehry or George Segal I suppose it
would be a disheartening statue of a man
looking at a map with the model
choo-choo in his hand the Ames Memorial
suggests infinity the King memorial
suggests wordplay in other words it is
book illustration it is the visual
diagram of ideas generated elsewhere it
is a good end index of where we stand
today mmm we are in a position now where
we are afraid to leave something out
this accounts for our addiction to
literalism but monumentality requires
fearless conviction and it can be done
and it doesn't necessarily require
neoclassicism what can we do first we
can recognize that it is possible to
make a convincing monument with the
means of modern architecture Saarinen
showed that it is possible with his
Gateway Arch at st. Louis an exquisite
portal to the West our version of a
Roman triumphal arch abstract but its
visual logic is direct and persuasive a
timeless opening into the continent the
second lesson is it is not too late
just because a world-famous architect
has submitted a design does not oblige
us to build it the history of this city
is crammed full of earnest and quite
sincere designs that were never
nevertheless politely shoved into a back
cupboard like this one for the
Washington Monument and the third lesson
is the third lesson is that greatness is
possible for more than a century and a
half we built great monuments with
spectacular success we have only been
building them badly for a generation I
look at these designs which are perhaps
an honest reflection of our divided an
uncertain culture and I can't help think
we can do better we have done better in
the past and we can do so again thank
you
there's a question right here professor
thank you for your facts and your
opinions I raised two possible questions
one you make no mention of the many
equestrian statues around town your
opinion would be requested and the other
is I'm I don't know if you're aware that
in one of the states I believe Utah
those roadside monuments to the death of
six state troopers was recently ruled
unconstitutional by a local judge
because it somehow combined government
and religion really that's outrageous I
did not I did not I did not know those
roadside shrines are very important they
say many things I can't begin to go into
their meaning today that's interesting
this this city has many great equestrian
statues I am out because I felt that my
talk like a monument had to leave things
out
I think the finest of all my opinion is
the great statue to grant by gleefully
behind the Capitol it is superb there
are many great ones throughout this city
and one of the joys of Washington
L'Enfant brilliant plan to Washington he
did not want a federal city with a
single point of power he wanted a
decentralized City and although
rondelle's offer multiple points for for
statuary and it's a pleasure to to go
anywhere in this in this low-slung
far-reaching city and to come upon an
equestrian statue i love
in Greenville with the National City
Guard Society um
there's I think a deeper problem to
doing monuments today and I think it's
some certain relativism that if you
don't agree on what is noble and good
they make a memorial or a monument to
that and I would say that was the
argument and that's my actual complaint
about the Vietnam Memorial is that the
men who fought there felt for the most
part they were about a noble business
and and to war and to end to put your
life in line for other people is always
noble and it is always good and good is
always beautiful and I think the scar in
the earth in black was not beautiful for
whatever it is it only commemorates the
loss but there was more to talk about
there than loss so but I think at that
time people didn't want to say there was
anything beautiful about Vietnam but but
whenever whenever a man sacrificed a
lock on the man there's there's beauty
there because there's nobility and
goodness and that's that's always
beautiful yeah that's a very that's a
very good point I agree it is a void and
every money every good monument has one
gesture and they're the gesture is is a
loss not a presence you could take away
that lesson I would have preferred
something more idealistic and positive
however I think it it is artistically
successful and the judgment for that is
it's public art and the public embraced
at the first day and the veterans who
opposed it as you know pretty much have
come have come to love it I would say
the lesson is nothing has divided us as
much as as Vietnam did nothing it is
possible even in our divided culture to
make a great unifying Monument maybe
perhaps that was not the one but it is
still possible so I I I disagree that
the necessary consequence of division is
a divided object but I take your point
my name is Michael Zack I wrote a
history of the Republican Party
thank you for noting that the roadside
crosses began in the 1980s am I right
about that yes you are and I'll add to
it that practice was brought to the US
by Latin American immigrants that
hundreds of years of roadside shrines to
loss in Latin America so that was a
cultural contribution from Latin America
and it's wonderful I think that's very
interesting that's very interesting
because at this point that's forgotten
they are now part of the common American
cultural coin interesting my name is
Erik boots my and I'm also with the
National Civic Art Society and I want to
thank you for putting up some of the
images that from the Eisenhower Memorial
your controversy because that is
something that our organization has been
working on revealing the truth about the
Eisenhower Memorial but one of the
things I found very interesting is that
you you did bring out the the
distinction between particularity and
universality that we have a problem
right now dealing with universality that
we have a problem with greatness
Aristotle of course mentions this in the
poetics that that poetry is more
philosophical and tells more truth than
history because it tells the way things
ought to be rather than what they
actually are and I think it's very
interesting that today Gary chooses to
use photographs to show eisenhower
rather than an image because he's
incapable of showing eisenhower is he
ought to be but that he can only show as
he was and so too with with a lot of the
memorials and I won't quibble any
further with a Vietnam Memorial but it
seems to be that a lot of them get
caught up in particular 'ti and so that
it they're they're very interested in
telling the truth is it actually was
rather than telling as Mr Grenfell
pointed out the way things ought to be
and the higher notions of greatness and
and of sacrifice and I might point then
further to Tocqueville who said that
there exists in the heart of men and
lawful and a good sense of equality that
seeks to raise every man up to the level
of greatness but there's also a perverse
sense of equality which rather than
lifting men great seeks to bring them
all down to their level that men would
prefer equality and slavery than
greatness to exist so I just like to see
your comment to whether or not you think
it's possible for us to find that
greatness again or are we caught in
particular t in the age that we live in
with Twitter and the 24-hour news cycle
that we're always caught in what is
actually true then what is poetically
true well that's a very big question
culture culture is a living thing and I
don't know the future there is no
question I see it my students that
Twitter has changed the the the mental
furniture of the minds of my students
how they process information I don't
know where that will go
i i like your focus on particularity
what do if i dis summarize I would say
particularity is what prevents these
things from being true monuments I would
offer this thought to you I wonder how
much this insistence on specifics
literal display of specifics is
connected to what happened to language
in the 1970s because there was a certain
moment it was about 1977 I was in
college I remember it you could no
longer say make a statement like man
does not live in bread alone because
people say well what about women so well
men and women cannot live them you and
the moment people began to pay attention
to the gender equality and other forms
of equality in their words they lost the
habit of the poetic generalization which
is essential for allegory I think that I
think there it relates to a nervousness
about ruling out and that pledges you to
a very painful strictly literal non
figurative language and now our
monuments are suffering from it as much
as our prose
could the contrast between what we see
today and what we have seen in the past
essentially be something like too many
cooks boil the soup yeah
committees you mean exactly exactly now
I see one of the committee members
behind you nodding vigorously yeah this
this city and New York are the hardest
cities in the world to get anything done
artistically because of the filters made
worse here I think that that is a big
part of it and the situation's got worse
and worse John Russell Pope was able to
design the Jefferson Memorial most
carte-blanche
now that world is venture I think you're
right yeah bureaucratic dilution - we
have time for one more I know where
we've got a time limit or a couple more
are we on here okay
what do I think of the Air Force
Memorial I'm asked si not bad not good
okay
excuse me earns upwards it has some
idealism I like that quality back there
man
I have you any knowledge of the Adams
Memorial oh here America's Finest
Memorial Augustus saint-gaudens the Adam
memorial here in Rock Creek Park that's
the battle
well not that Adams oh no okay they're
there they're going to owe to President
Adams yes to John Adams Abigail Oh John
Quincy I do not know you know nothing
about that no but I doubt it will be
with America's greatest monuments well
from I'm gonna an atom's descendant and
from what I hear you're absolutely right
this will be a final question yeah thank
you
my name's Nicholson I had the privilege
of being the CEO and the Secretary of
the American battle monuments Commission
responsible for overseas American
monuments and cemeteries dedicated to
those Americans who lost their lives
ejecting invaders from our allies
countries and restoring their freedom
and there are 23 of those cemeteries
around the world to put it in the words
of a former chief of state of a European
country who said and who does still say
in many of his speeches when I was 8
years old my father took me to the Anzio
cemetery and said to me look at those
graves most of them are for boys between
the ages of 18 and 25 who left their
homes to come here and restore freedom
in our country don't forget it well this
chief estate goes one of those
year and he takes his chit his kids and
his grandchildren millions of Europeans
not just from the countries who were
freed up by Americans by those hundreds
of thousands of Americans who died doing
that but from Eastern European countries
and Asian countries go to those
memorials and I respectfully suggest to
you sir please try to mention that
because outside the United States
that is a big factor in people's opinion
about our country thank you sir
beautifully said beautifully said I
thank you for the reminder and thank you
for your attention today and putting up
with my failing voice thank you